yale professor and happiness expert lori
santos that's fun turns her attention to
fun in the new season of her popular
podcast it's called the happiness lab
which has more than 35 million downloads
takes a look at what really makes people
happy season three begins this week and
two of the episodes focus on the
importance of fun in what she calls a
fun intervention for herself i like this
word lori santos joins us now to discuss
hey lori santos we were just talking to
ethan hawk who told us during the break
he's in a undisclosed location but he
said as soon as he gets done here he's
going to go tubing and he's going to go
biking and he's hanging out with his
kids i'm thinking he knows how to do
this right so when you say fun
intervention do some people not know how
to have fun
well i think like a lot of adults don't
know how to have fun right we prioritize
work you know so much that we get
exhausted and then when we finally get
some free time we're so burnt out that
we just like plop down and watch you
know netflix or something and that's
enjoyable it might be relaxing but it's
not
fun like you know time is flying by
you're energized feeling connected like
that's what's fun and so many of us just
aren't getting enough of that in our
lives well and during the pandemic it's
it's been awfully easy to be in in kind
of a fun slump what do you do to get out
of it
yeah well part of it is to really like
actually take some time to look at fun
and what's fun in your life you know i
was inspired to do this by the
journalist catherine price who has this
fantastic book called the power of fun i
talked to her from my podcast is she
suggest taking a fun audit where you
kind of go back and say okay you know
what are the times in my life that i was
most having fun you know singing in the
car with my kids or you know having this
like you know fun verbal spat with like
my spouse or something like what are the
parts where you really enjoy it and how
can you build more of that into your
life i understand one of the things you
tried in a fun intervention in your life
uh was surfing how'd that go
yeah well what i realized one of the
reasons i wasn't having fun was that i'm
not good at doing new things or things i
was going to be bad at so i picked
something that i knew as like a you know
out of shape 40 year old woman i might
be bad at which was surfing and i you
know took a surf lesson with one of my
good college friends in rhode island and
it was incredibly fun i mean you know
you see from the pictures it doesn't
necessarily look like we're like point
break or anything but we're smiling the
whole time in fact you know i did this
yesterday i'm pretty sore today but
what's most sore is my face from smiling
and laughing so much what do you say to
people especially adults and say oh
you're acting like a child that's
childish and i look at those people and
go is that wrong
yeah i mean you know it is childish but
the thing is is that what we know from
fun is that fun can be so important for
our well-being you know playfulness can
boost your immune function playfulness
can boost your mood it can protect your
mental health you know can lead to less
burnout over time it's one of the
easiest interventions we have for
building up our mental health we just
don't realize how powerful it is you say
it requires self-compassion what do you
mean
well you know take surfing for example
you know i think you know there's so
many things we could try as an adult
that might be really fun but we kind of
think like oh i should know how to do
that or it's too childish or it's too
foolish i think we need some
self-compassion to just be nice to
ourselves to try to be a beginner again
your kids are having fun all the time
and it's often because they're totally
doing new stuff we stopped doing that as
an adult so with a little more
compassion you know a little less
judgment we might be better off i like
that a little more compassion a little
less judgment uh you're writing a song
here live on air if uh if people were
asking their boss for that time off uh
to have a little fun would you advise
that they use the word fun intervention
[Laughter]
and say lori santos said yeah
yeah i think you just remind your boss
that you know this is the kind of thing
that can lead to less burnout and we
should also remember that fun can happen
you don't have to go surfing every day
to have fun you can build it in in small
increments you know thinking about the
things that make your day happy the
things that you really kind of enjoy
that make you playful build more of
those things in
i always say lori you could not be
unhappy if you're skipping
if you're singing or if you're swinging
on a swing where you're just kicking
your legs up and going we i
i defy anybody to do that and not say
that was fun
i agree and you know i think singing is
another big one another one of my
interventions is uh you know singing
karaoke sing-alongs do not like singing
to the profession yep singing even if
you're a bad singer is fun thank you
lori santos always good to see you the
happiness lab is available wherever you
listen to your podcast you're watching
cbs this morning we always appreciate
that we'll be right back